we're just three days out from the first
major contest of the 2024 primary season
the very cold chilly Iowa caucuses
Ingram mangle will be on the ground in
De Mo on Monday to bring you political
analysis you're not going to see it
anywhere else I think it's my eighth
Iowa caucuses and I'm attending looking
forward to it but our show is the only
thing of course coming to town uh the
blizzard you've heard about that the
weather coldest in caucus history so how
will this or will this change the
Dynamics for Monday's turnout joining me
now is Republican presidential candidate
in Florida Governor Rona santis Governor
I know um you're making a final pitch um
what is your pitch given you know Nikki
Haley gaining a little bit of ground on
you and Iowa and obviously Trump still
in the lead what's the pitch in these
Final
hours well first Laura you know us
Floridians usually don't go north in the
middle of a blizzard and so you know
we're here obviously competing and I've
got a lot of folks uh from my staff in
the past that are volunteering to knock
on doors and help out so it's an
interesting experience to see all the
Floridians my son was throwing snowballs
at me uh today and that's not something
that he had ever even seen uh a month
and a half ago so look our pitch is
simple uh Donald Trump's running for his
issues Nikki Haley's running for her
donor's issues I'm running for your
issues and your family's issues as
somebody that's delivered on 100% of my
promises as governor of Florida and as
the only candidate running that is taken
on the left and beaten the left on issue
after issue we beat the teachers unions
we beat fouchy we beat George Soros on
crime we beat the Democrats on Election
integrity and on illegal immigration uh
and we beat the left by Banning China
from buying land in the State of Florida
so we have the ability to produce big
results and I think you know you talk
about this weather we our approach to
the Iowa was that a caucus is different
than a primary or typical election and
so you have to really build an
organization that's going to be able to
turn out your commitments on caucus
night which may not be the the best
environment and now we did not expect it
to be -22 when we did it but I do feel
that we're in a situation where our
folks are going to show up uh we've got
every Precinct organized every County
organized uh and that's going to pay
dividends and it was a lot of hard work
the media was saying that I was wasting
my time they were saying that why are
you going to all 99 counties and I think
this is why we've been able to build um
a solid following and look anyone that
says they can take a poll and figure out
who's going to turnout on Monday is not
being honest nobody knows what the
turnout's going to be like I could just
tell you that we've put an organization
in place where our folks are going to
turn out well Governor the news just
came right before the show tonight that
after Iowa you're going straight to
South Carolina um traditionally
candidates would go to New Hampshire the
next contest I know you're going back um
to New Hampshire shortly after but what
kind of message is that
sending well you're right thanks for
saying it on accurately because some
media was saying we weren't doing here
it's not true we're going to do an event
in Greenville on Tuesday Morning uh and
then we're going to fly to New Hampshire
and do a town hall um on CNN later that
night and do a lot of stuff in New
Hampshire but I think the message is
simple that you know you look at South
Carolina Nikki Haley was governor there
and I've got like five times more
endorsements from state legislators
current and former than she does and at
that be Unthinkable for the opposite to
happen a place like Florida and so she's
really out of Step I think with with
South Carolina uh we're going to show
that uh with with the support we have
and people have been focusing on Iowa
but we've been building these
organizations in New Hampshire and in
South Carolina as well uh didn't get as
much fanfare but that's the case so yes
we'll start in South Carolina do New
Hampshire we have a debate scheduled on
Thursday in New Hampshire WM debate I'm
the only one that's accepted that debate
I hope the debate happens but if not
I'll be there if they want to do a town
hall I'm game debate debate the Nikki
Haley chair um now Governor um Senate
Republican leader Mitch McConnell um as
I started the show with is escalating
his personal efforts to push this
so-called bipartisan border reform uh
deal tying it up with Ukraine and Israel
for some reason um we find out that
they're going to be able to Greenlight
5,000 migrants a day into the United
States more efficiently settle them 1.82
5 million migrants waved into the
country plus all these other foreign
workers waved in um your reaction
tonight um as Republicans are beginning
I think to peel away from
this well uh when I'm present that'll be
dead on arrival um you know some of
these Republicans are just so out of
touch with the voters Laura I've got all
99 counties in Iowa it's not a border
state and yet every single Town Hall I
do uh I get multiple questions about
illegal immigration and about the Border
republ Republicans want people that are
here illegally to be deported which we
need to do uh they want to end these
insane border policies that Biden's
doing yes they want a wall they want to
see that done uh and they also want to
see action against the drug cartels and
I think what you're likely to see out of
this deal is the typical Lucy with the
football promising you're going to deal
with the border and then of course the
football gets pulled away and it's the
same old song and dance the end of the
day there are some uh Republicans and I
would say Nikki Haley's one of them uh
you know they want the the open borders
because the donors want it for the cheap
labor uh we got to start putting the
American people first and stop worrying
about uh you know these guys that that
don't care about our sovereignty we're
going to lose this country if you keep
allowing millions and millions of people
to come in at this rate it has to stop
so Governor you tell these Republicans
No Deal
correct of course not the the only deal
would be house bill house resolution 2
that chip Roy who's a supporter of mine
has put put forward it solves all the
problems and it would actually cause the
The Surge to stop and anything short of
that is just not going to do the job so
I would say any Republican in Congress
uh no half measures uh no failure
theater if you can get something that
actually solves the problem fine but I
don't think there's any way in heck that
Biden would agree to something that
actually solves the problem this is part
of the left's agenda to have open
borders and he's not going to go his go
against his base on this uh given his
his bad political standing well Governor
I I thought that would be the answer and
I'm delighted to hear that um we're
going to be in De Moine on Monday um
will you join us on
set I I don't I got to know where I'm I
don't know where I'm going to be I'm
going to speak at a couple caucus
locations so let us get back to you if
I'm in the de MO area I would love to do
it all right Governor thank you so much
we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else